[Music]
the design of this soy sauce bottle goes
back to 1945 in Japan a teenager named
Ken Jia Quan had witnessed the aftermath
of the atomic bomb falling on his
hometown hiroshima and was mourning the
loss of his sister and father after
seeing the devastation at wons path
changed he first enrolled as a Buddhist
monk falling in the footsteps of his
father but instead he decided to become
a creator of things and bring happiness
to people as a young designer at Guan
got a contract to design a tabletop soy
sauce bottle for food company Kikkoman
soy sauce is a must for Japanese meals
but it was originally sold in big
bottles that were hard to hold it took
at gone three years and about a hundred
prototypes to complete the design in
1961 the result is a small glass bottle
with a narrow neck a shape reminiscent
of traditional Japanese sake flasks it
allows you to see how much sauce is left
it's stable on surfaces and comfortable
to hold the inward angle of the tip of
the spout is also perfect at preventing
drips and controlling flows the design
of the little soy sauce bottle was just
the start of that guan's a great journey
he also went on to create other icons of
Japanese design
in Japan a Kwan has become almost as
recognizable as his bottle and fifty
years later still appeared in
commercials for the soy sauce today the
bottle can be found on the tables of
homes and restaurants in more than 100
countries and in 2015 the bottle was
even exhibited at the Museum of Modern
Art in New York simple but elegant this
is the design made to create a small
moment of happiness without you even
knowing
[Music]
you